[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم في حلقه جديده من برنامج من
المصدر المهتم بتحليل مشهد الاعلامي
العربي والعالمي هذا الاسبوع شغل الاعلام
الدولي بثلاث مواضع اساسيه نحاول ان نشرح
خلفيات طرحها في
الاعلاميه الدولي
استعاده اوكرانيا لمدينه خرسون بين اعلام
غربي شامت وتوعد الجنسيه غاضب
في امريكا المشهد الاعلاميه تبدل بعد
نتائج الانتخابات النصفيه المخيبه للحزب
الجمهوري نيران صديقه من اعلام الجمهوريين
تصيب ترامب بشكل لاذع بالتجامل مع اعلان
اعتدامه الترشح في السباق الرئاسي القادم
انظار العالم توجهت نحو اول لقاء يجمع بين
رئيس اكبر اقتصاديين في العالم في ضوء
توتر العلاقات بينهما في الفتره الاخيره
ضبط ايقاع الخلاف في عصر المواجهه كمعن
ونتميورك تايمز قد نلخص مشهد لقاء
الزعيمين على هامشي قمه العشرين في بالي
لا مضطرين الامريكي والصيني شدد على اهميه
التعاون المشترك من اجل استقرار العالم
[موسيقى]
لم يخلو الامر من بعض التعليقات النقديه
في الشكل ايضا الخبير الامريكي في الشان
الصيني جوردنشان علق في تغريده على طريقه
التحيه التي القاها بيضا على الرئيس شيك
وقال انه في اللقاء الاول الذي جمع
الزعيمين لعب الرئيس الصيني دورا المضيف
حينما انتظر في مكان حتى ياتي اليه الرئيس
الامريكي ليلقي التحيه واعتبر ان ذلك
بمثابه مناوره لاظهار امريكا انها الطرف
الضعف في المعادله الدوليه وتساءلت شان
لماذا قبل الرئيس بايرن في
هذاتنا الى بالناديل البيسي اهلا بك يا
ناديه كيف كانت ردت فعل الصحفيين وتعامل
الصحافيين الصينيين والامريين مع قمه
التي حظيت باهتمام عالمي كبير
اهلا بك جلال في الواقع هذه القمه كانت
قمه العمالقه كما تعرفين الصين تريد ان
تطيح بالولايات المتحده من المركز الاول
اكبر منافس لها اقتصاديه وبالتالي كان
الكثير من الاهتمام الاعلامي سواء كان من
الصحفيين المرافقين للرئيس بايدن انا طبعا
واحده منهم او من الصحفيين بكل اسيا في
الواقع ليس فقط من الصين كما تعرفين
الرئيس بعدين يعرف منذ فتره طويله عندما
كان نائب للرئيس لكن اا سال الرئيس كيف
تصف هذا اللقاء الذي استمر اكثر من ثلاث
ساعات ونصف جلال هذا يعني بانه كان لقاء
جيد يعني كل ما كان طويلا كل ما كان افضل
هل كان رئيس شيشه مثلا همم تصادمي او كان
مسالم ااه رئيس بيض قال بانه كان عهدته
يتحدث بطريقه مباشره هناك قضايا كثيره
اتفقنا عليها مثل موضوع عدم استخدام تلحقه
النوويه همم ومواضيع اخرى طبعا لكن كما
تعرفين موضوع تايوان هو والحاضر الغائب
دوما في هذا الملف همم وربما كان هناك
اطمئنا من الرئيس بيادر لرئيس شيبانغ بانه
الولايات المتحده لم تغير سياستها تجاه
تايوان اي الصين الواحده وهو تحذير ايضا
يعني ممكن يقرا من الناحيتين لكن هو كان
اللقاء الاهم في عليها مش هذه القمه همم
وطبعا همم كان هناك تركيز على من يقترب من
من الذي يبدا بالمصافحه لانه بالنهايه
بالفعل هو همم عملاق صيني او عملاق امريكي
وتنين صيني ومن يقترب من الاخر كانت تركيز
كثير على هذه النقطه نعم كيف كانت ردت فعل
الصحفيين الصينيين
والامريكيين على لغه الجسد بين الزعيمين
يعني كانت جيده الاجواء كانت بالفعل
ايجابيه على الاقل من وجهه نظر الوفد
الامريكي اكثر من مسؤول طبعا في البيت
الابيض كان يتحدث معنا طول هذه الرحله قال
بان رئيس بيدن كان يمزح عاده يقول بانه
قطع 7000 17000 مين لحتى يذهب الى الصين
للقاء شيشي باني عندما كان نائب للرئيس
والكل كان يعرف بانه سيكون القائد القادم
من الصين وهذا ما حصل بالفعل على مدى
ولايتين والان البعض يرى بان شيبه هو
القائد عماد الحياه يعني لانه تم انتخابه
من قبل الحزب الشيعي همم اعتقد بانه بعيد
يعني لديه لغه جسد كما رايناها كانت
مرتاحه نوعا ما همم مع الرئيس الصيني
وكذلك لكن بالنسبه
لكن بغض النظر دائما هناك وجهان للحقيقه
يعني همم بالنسبه لوجهه النظر الامريكيه
الموضوع ايجابي لكن الوجه الناظر الصينيه
يمكن ان تنقلب الامور لك ليكون وكان شيش
بي هو الذي يسيطر على هذا الاجتماع وليس
العكس مفاده العربيه الى بالي من في
اندونيسيا شكرا جزيلا لك
هذا اللقاء الذي شغل العالم ياتي لتوضيح
معالم العلاقات وتحديدها بين اكبر قوتين
في العالم بعد اربعه عقود من الشراكه
المربحه لكل الطرفين بدا كل طرف ينحو
للاستقلال عن الاخر بتعزيز النسب الاكتفاء
الذاتي بشكل اكبر مع تنامي حده التوتر في
اعلان كلاب طرفين في الفتره الاخيره
العلاقات التجاريه تراجعت اهميتها مقارنه
باولويه الامن القومي بالنسبه الى امريكا
كما قالت واشنطن بوست في عنوان لها انه من
الواضح ان الطرفين اصبح مستعده للتضحيه
بالمكاسب الاقتصاديه لاسباب امنيه هذا
سيما يحذر الاقتصاديون من تبعات ذلك
الانشقاق على الاقتصاد العالميه
نذكر ان قبل القمه في ذلك نوع عنوان
الابرز في الاعلام الامريكي كيفيه احتواء
الصين التي تهدد مكانه امريكا في ضوء
القرارات الاخيره التي اتخذتها اداره
وايضا من اجل الحدي من التشارك مع ثاني
اكبر اقتصاد في العالم
[موسيقى]
الانعطافه الكبرى في العلاقات كانت تجلد
في قرار اداره بيلا بمنع تصدير الرقائق
الالكترونيه الى الصين اقوى خطوه في اطار
استراتيجيه لاحتواء التقدم التكنولوجي
الصيني العمود الفقري لجميع الصناعات
الحديثه ولمواجهه هذا التحدي تتجه الصين
الى اقوى اشكال القوميه التكنولوجيه نيورك
تايمز وتتخذ السلطات سلسله التدابير لسد
النقص الامريكي على مستوى صناعه الرقائق
علما ان 30% من الارباح الشركات الامريكيه
تدورها من صادراتها الى الصين على مستوى
الرقائق
لكن يبدو كما ظهر في قمه بالي ان الامور
تتجه الى الاداره للصراع وفق صحيفه فنان
سلطان
مبادئ اولا فصل الاقتصادين لا ينبغي ان
يؤدي الى انهيار الاقتصاد العالمي ثانيا
تجنب الحرب الكبرى والتعاون لا يزال
مطلوبا في مجموعه من القضايا
بهذا السياق نسال لنخضر كوفسكي من معهد
المتخصص بمواجهه التقدم التكنولوجي الصيني
كيف راى اللقاء بين الزعيمين الصيني
والامريكي خاصه وهو خبير في علم التواصل
ايضا اهلا بك استاذ لن
توعيه افكار
اختصاصيه اتصال يهتم بالحركات والمعاني
والمتابعات فمن المهم الظهور في وضع قوه
وهو ما تهدف له سياستنا لذلك من المهم ان
يعكس مظهرنا جوهر سياستنا بما يعني انه
يتعين ان يقابل الصين بمقاربه بموقع قوه
فنعم كل شيء مهم لكن منشغل اكثر بجوهر
المحادثات ومعناها وكيف ان الولايات
المتحده او اصدقائها تذهب ليس فقط لمواجهه
طموحات السن في مجلس سيطرتها على العالم
ولكن ما يتعين علينا فعله على واجهه الدقه
لكبح جمال حسين هذا هو الاهم بالنسبه الى
الولايات او اصدقائنا عبر العالم
قديم قديم
الصراع في المرحله المقبله كما قيل في
الاعلام الامريكي
الاولويه القصوى بالنسبه الى الولايات
المتحده ولذلك فان الاجتماع مهم والان مع
حصول الرئيس الشيعه على عهده ثالثه ما
يجعل منه عمليا امبراطور مدى الحياه للصين
فانه كان من المهم للرئيس ان يظهر اولويات
السياسه الامريكيه وعلى مختلف الاصعد بما
فيها مخاوفنا الدبلوماسيه والعسكريه
والتكنولوجيه والثقافيه وان الصين هي
التهديد في كل هذه المجالات نعم كان
الاجتماع مهما وامول ان الرئيس بيضا لم
ينسى ما كان ينبغي قوله
من معهد من المصدر مستمر وبعض الفاصل
افريقيا ممازحه من فيل تقود مراسلا كينيا
الى الشهره العالميه
اهلا بكم من جديد
في الاعلام الدولي في مكان الاعلام
الروسيه
قبلت بشماته غربيه وفق تعبير الصحيفه
البريطانيه دبلوفي نيوز اكو اذا اعتبرتها
بريطانيا اهانه اخرى للجيش الروسي فيما
الولايات المتحده اعتبرتها انتصارا غير
عديلي اوكرانيا ويعد انسحاب روسيا من غير
سون ثالث تراجع رئيسي لها في الحرب
الاوكرانيه
فبذلك سقطت احدى المناطق الاربعه التي
اعلنت روسيا استقلالها عن اوكرانيا بعيده
تطبيق الاستفتاء بعد ان شنت القوات
الاوكرانيه هجوما على مواقع القوات
الروسيه واستهداف الطرق المؤديه للمدينه
لقطع الامدادات للجيش الروسي الذي وجد
نفسه محاصرا نيوز لذلك انسحبت القوات
الروسيه من مدينه خرسان الاوكرانيه الى
مواقع دفاعيه الى الضفه اليسرى لنهر تلك
المدينه الاستراتيجيه تعد المنفذ الاقرب
الى جزيره القرم التي استولت عليها روسيا
في عام 2014
الاعلام الروسيه كان قد بدا قبل ثلاثه
اسابيع بتحضير الجمهور باحتماليه استعاده
اوكرانيا لخرصان الاستراتيجيه وهي اول
عاصمه اسلاميه استولت عليها روسيا لدى
هجومها في فبراير الماضي
كان الجانب الاوكراني يعمل بصفه منهجيه
على قطع طرق يمداد قواتنا على مستوى منطقه
الان تحديدا تعد الجوانب اللوجستيه على
الضفه اليسرى من نهر النيبرو معقده جدا
بالطبعه تم ايصالها باستخدام جسور عائمه
وعبارات وللاسف لا توجد حاليا اتصالات
كامله بين ضفه النهر وهو ما يدعو صعوبات
امام القوات الروسيه
اذا بسقوط خرسون فشلت روسيا باستعاب
المدينه وضمها قوميا الى اراضيها وفقا
نيورك تايمز روسي حضرت الاغاني الوطنيه
ومنعت الاعلام الاوكرانيه وهددت بسجن من
يتكلم باللغه الاوكرانيه وقيل للطلاب انهم
روس
حفاوت اهالي خرسون بدخول الجيش الاوكراني
دليل على تعلق الاهالي بانتمائهم
الاوكراني رغم الاستفتاء الذي نظمته روسيا
بضم المدينه الى روسيا وحفلت مواقع
التواصل بصور نمشي اعلامي اوكرانيا كانت
خبيات في اماكن سريه في الازقه خشيه من
القوات الروسيه هذا الفيديو لسيدات استرجع
على منخبائته بعد سيطره روسيا على المدينه
انتشر كالنار في الهاشم
مصدر هذا الفيديو من خيرسون ابن هذه
السيده التي ينضم الينا لنساله لماذا
برايك انتشر هذا الفيديو وكيف تصف لنا
الاجواء الان اهلا بك
[موسيقى]
تشهد عمليات تفتيش من طرف الجنود الروس
اتصلت بامي وطلبت منها اخفاء العالم
الاوكراني مخافه ان يتسبب لها في مشاكل
الا انها اكدت انها اخفت العالم بعنايه
وحتى تثبت لذلك قامت بتصوير مقطع فيديو في
الحادي عشر من الشهر الحالي عندما تم
تحرير خرسان اتصلت بعائله الذين ارسلوا
الي مقطع الفيديو وقمت بنشره على انستغرام
بمرور ساعات انتشر المقطع في اوكرانيا ثم
في العالم اجمع وعيدا نشر الفيديو في
الكثير من المنصات الشهيره في اوكرانيا
لكن امي لا تعلم انها اصبحت مشهوره
نقطه
الاستفتاء الاغلبيه تريد الاستقلال عن
اوكرانيا كيف جرى الاستفتاء اخرصون
لقد ذهبوا الى البيوت ليس اليها كلها طبعا
حملنا صناديق الاقتراع وبحراسه عسكريه لقد
قاموا بتحضير اقل ما يلزم من اجل اجراء
الاستفتاء هذا ليس الاستثاءا كيف يمكنك
الاختيار عندما يضعون رشاشا فوق راسه هذا
خيال وليس استفتاء
شكرا جزيلا ايجار من خيرصون وفيما كان
الاوكرانيون يحتفلون باستعاده خرسان كانت
روسيا تتواعد وفق رصد الاعلام الروسيه
وقلت انه من المرجح جدا ان هدفخ ولكنني
الان اتحدث عن فخ عالمي دولي اكبر حاليا
حدود بولندا وسلوفاكيا وتشيكيا وتملا كل
اوكرانيا واثر ذلك مدمرهم جميعا
ولكن رغم القلق الواضح في روسيا الى ان
الاعلام الغربيه يخشى من استراتيجيه جديده
لروسيا قد تقلب الموازين من جديد ذلك لان
الرئيس بوتين ليس مستعجلا وارى نفسه في
معركه طويله الامد مع الغرب حيث تنقل مجله
تايم عن مسؤول عسكريا غربي كبير قوله ان
الانسحاب من خرسوم يظهر تغييرا في تفكير
سيد الكرملين ويضيف المسؤول ان كوتينيس
عائله تجميد النزاع لكسب الوقت بهدف اعاده
بناء جيشه وتدريب جنود الاحتياط الذين تم
استدعائهم مؤخرا فان جغرافيا المنطقه
ستسمح للجيش الروسي ببناء تحصينات اخرى
وستكون مهمه عبور نهر النيل صعبه جدا على
الجيش الاخراني المهاجم
لذلك تتطلع واشنطن الى الدبلوماسيه قبل ان
يبطئ الشتاء زخم الحرب وتبقي روسيا على
مكاسبها
كبار المسؤولين في واشنطن بداوا يتساءلون
بصوت عال عن مقدار المزيد من الاراضي التي
يمكن لاي من الجانبين كسبها وباي كلفه يجب
ان يكون هناك اعتراف متبادل بان النصر
العسكري بالمعنى الحقيقي للكلمه ربما لا
يمكن تحقيقه من خلال الوسائل العسكريه
لذلك تحتاج الى اللجوء الى وسائل اخرى
ومنها المفاوضات
في امريكا يتغير المشهد الاعلامي بشكل
لاست غدا اعلان نتائج الانتخابات النصفيه
التي جاءت مخيبه للامان بالجسمه الى الحزب
الجمهوري الانتقاد من داخل الحزب الجمهوري
لترامب الذي كان حتى الامس القريب الزعيم
الاوحد للحزب ياخذ حيزا واسعا في الاعلام
الديمقراطيه بطبيعه الحال ولكن مفارقه انه
ينتشر اكثر في الاعلام الحزب الجمهوري
الذي ينتمي اليه هذا الاسبوع انقسمت شاشات
القنوات الاخباريه الامريكيه بين اعلان
للانتخابات الرئاسيه المقبله والتحليل هذا
الاعلام وبين سلسله لقاءات بانس نائب
ترامب السابق الذي اطال الانتقادي حكم
ترامب وعرقله التي تعبيره
طبعا الاعلام المقرب من الديمقراطيين
استغل نغمات على ترامب وافرد له السلسله
طريقه لتسويق كتابه الجديد الذي ينتقد فيه
الاجرام خاصه فيما يتعلق باحداث 6 يناير
باقتحام مبنى الكونجرس المتهم ترامب
بالثعالها على شبكه اي بي سي فقد بانس
سلوك رئيسه السابق والذي وصفه بالمتهور
فارس عبر عن يقينهم من ان الولايات
المتحده سيكون لها خيارات افضل من ترامب
في منصب الرئيس واكد انه هو نفسه يفكر في
التراجع ضد ترامب تحديا له ولك قطع الطريق
على رئيسه السابق وفي ظهوره الاخر على
الشاشه العدوه لترامب سي ان ان شدد هجوم
عليه مع نجم سي ان ان جاكبر اما ظهوره
الثانيه فكان على فوكس نيوز الجمهوريه حيث
ايضا حوار مع شين هانتي وانتقد ترامب مره
اخرى ولكن بلهجه مخففه واذكر انهانتي عرف
بمناصيرته لترامب
بذلك اوقع الرئيس الجمهوريه السابق في
مرمى النيران الصديقه من الاعلام الموالي
لحزب الجمهوري ذلك لان الحزب الجمهوري
يعيد حساباته بعد هزيمه معظم مرشحي ترامب
في الانتخابات النصفيه التي جاءت عكس
توقعاتهم بفوز ساحق موقع ميديا ميترز
عنوان فرقه الاعدام في الاعلام الجمهوري
ضد ترامب في ضوء نتائج الانتخابات
وعلى راسي فرقه الاعدام تلك تاتي
الامبراطوريه الاعلاميه التي يملكها روبرت
مارد التي تضم كبر المؤسسات المرموقه في
الاعلام المحافظه
في هذا السياق انتشر مقطع لمعلق في فوكس
نيوز
كثيره بعد
انتقالهم خسر الحزب الجمهوري مجلس الشيوخ
مرتين واصبح عبئا على الحزب وعلى جمهوريين
الالتفاف الى الفائزين كاران ديسنتس الذي
يظهر اسمه بقوه بعد فوزه الكبير في
فلوريدا نحو 20 نقطه
انا عارف
[موسيقى]
الكاتب الشخصي للرئيس اصبغ جورج بوش في
رساله مفتوحه طلب فيها ترامب عدم الترشح
الرساله وجهها عبر واشنطن قوس بعنوان
العزيزه الرئيس ترامب نرجو عدم ترشحك من
جديد وقال حفاظا على ارتكا وعلى فرص الحزب
الجمهوري بالفوز من جديد
من خلال كيفيه تغطيه كبرى القنوات
الامريكيه لخطاب اعلان ترشحها فيما قررت
عدم همم في مقررات اماس ام بي سي عدم بث
الخطاب على الهواء مباشره قطعت سي ان
انبسها من بيتش مقر ترامب بعد نحوي 25
دقيقه في بثت فوكس نيوز حوالي 40 دقيقه من
الخطاب اما نيوز ماكس فبست الخطاب كامله
رئيس قناه نيوز ماكس المحافظه السيد
كريستوفر رودي ماذا كانت ستغير نيوز ماكس
خطها التحريري بدعم ترامب كما لاحظنا في
قناه فوكس نيوز المحافظه ايضا فرد بي جواب
لا مع علامه تعجب ما يعني ان دعم المحطه
مستمر للرئيس السابق وقال لنا الرئيس رودي
ان المحطه ستعطي فرصه للجميع بطريقه عادله
ومن ضمنهم ديسانتس ايضا
ولكن بشكل عام كما تقول نيو بوس المواليه
للحزب الجمهوري خطاب ترامب للترشح تم
تجهوله والتعتيم عليه في القنوات
التلفزيونيه الرئيسيه تغيرون حقيقي
ان الشركه ستستمر في حضره ترامب ولكنها لن
تحقق او تعالج البيانات التي تصدر عنه او
التي يتناقلها المستخدمون عنه
فوكس نسب المشاهده للانتخابات النصفيه في
امريكا في اوقات الذروه في محلات سي ان ان
في المرتبه الثانيه وفق الارقام الصادره
عن موقع ميديا لها مثلا بي سي من حيث عدد
المشاهده التي لم تصل الى نصف عدد
المشاهدات
وافقتين يا مراسله تلفزيون يتعرض الى موقف
محرج من قبل فيل الذي قرر ان يمازحه على
الهواء مباشره المراسل الذي كان يتكلم على
ضروره الحفاظ على الانواع الحيوانيه قبل
انقراضها يبدو انه لاق تشجيعا على كلامه
من قبل الفيله
ومع هذا نصل الى نهايه حلقتنا لليوم
موعدنا يتجدد الاسبوع المقبل شكرا
[موسيقى]